we've covered using cloud trace to
measure latency on our services and open
census to collect custom metrics lemon
tree already but what if you could use a
single library to accomplish both today
I'll introduce you to open telemetry the
next major release of open census and
show you how to use it for distributed
tracing this is the stack dr as our
applications become more complex and
more services are involved in serving
user traffic and completing transactions
it becomes more and more critical to
understand how requests traverse our
services and how each service
contributes to overall latency this is
what distributed tracing does it
captures the latency of user requests
and how long it takes each micro service
in the path to return a response the
next release of open census is merging
the open tracing project in a new open
source project called open telemetry
which provides a single set of api's
libraries agents and collector services
to capture distributed traces and
metrics from your application open
telemetry is a cognitive computing
foundation sandbox project and I'm here
today to show you how to use it for
tracing let's start by reviewing the
basics these were originally described
in Google's research paper on the dabber
distributed tracing framework we'll link
to it below if you'd like to read it
when our user request comes in we want
to create a trace the total of
information that describes how our
system responds to user request traces
are composed of spans where each span
represents a specific request and
response pair involved in serving the
user request the parent span describes
the latency as observed by the end user
each of the child spans describes how a
particular service in distributed system
was called and responded with latency
information captured for each let's take
a look at a basic example we have a
front-end service that responds to user
requests and makes calls to a back-end
service it has to wait on that back-end
call to complete to return the response
back to the user we want to trace this
interaction to understand both total
latency and latency for each service in
the front-end code we start tracing and
create the route span we then make a
request to the backend with the
appropriate context this is data
embedded in the HTTP headers that our
back-end can use to append subsequent
spans to our trace in the backend code
we extract the context from the incoming
request and use it to create additional
spans this allows us to
measures latency of our backyard service
further we can create custom spans if
for example we want a time how long
specific background tasks might take
when we look at trace in the cloud
console we can see our trace capture
with detailed information about how long
each step in the interaction takes open
telemetry takes it a step further by
exposing details about the network
interactions between our services we can
even see how long it took to do the DNS
resolution establish a connection I'm
incredibly excited by the promise of the
open telemetry project next time we'll
take a look at how to use open telemetry
together custom metric telemetry from
our services that's it for this episode
this is the stack dr. stay healthy out
there
[Music]